I'm gonna show you the product rule I'm
going to prove your point okay you don't
have to reproduce the proof but I want
you to know where it comes from
okay so let's start off
okay so is you're going to start I've
got my function why but it's part of two
other functions okay
like x squared and x squared minus one
just like we were dealing with okay so
if I've got a product here what would be
it derivative well so far when we want
to work stuff out we always go back to
first principles and that's exactly what
we're going to do here okay
so figure out this usually we say you
know if Y is a function we want Y - how
do we define first principles where we
start with thank you we start with the
limit as H approaches zero of there just
quoted for me just normal basic first
principles what's on the top f of X plus
h - okay so that's the rise and then
you've got the run happy so far okay
good
now this case our f is a little more
complex right more complicated it's got
these two bits to it so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to take this and set
it F's I want use and Vees okay what's
it gonna look like well this next line
is going to be
before I do it when you have a good
write down what would you put as your
next line I want to get rid of all the
FS replace that we've used in these
because it's what I actually have what
we do next slide look like I'll give you
a second to think about it and jot it
down
okay does it match it looks like an
awful mess doesn't it but all I've done
is I've just replaced apps with use and
beans you can see there's a product okay
I'll um I'll put some color around it
there's the first product and there's
the second one okay
music f of X you've been ok so there's
just a straight substitution now at this
point what am I gonna do in order to get
to the price rule things are going to
look a lot worse before they get better
and so before I do this the next step I
just want to remind you in maths we
learn techniques like this like say
rationalizing the denominator right so
if I gave you this okay in order to make
this simpler we first make it more
complicated right we multiply by extra
stuff so that we can you know expand
this with difference of squares and
eventually it looks better right in the
same way you know when you're doing a
circle
if I give you a second let's hit tell me
the center of the radius okay what do
you have to do this to workout center
minutes those features you complete the
square right which is adding staff and
then it gets bigger and stuff is getting
worse
just like with rationalizing before it
gets better okay so I'm going to make
this look a lot worse in order to get to
something simpler
okay and by the way here if you're
trying to do columns Daniel page they're
about to explore this is gonna be a
great one here's what I'm gonna do on
the numerator I'm going to add something
and I'm gonna subtract something so that
my net difference is zero something like
here you multiply and you divide by
something okay now what i'm gonna add
and subtract will look a little can
intuitive at first but hopefully the
reason why will come out in the middle
okay so we started building it and i've
already got this okay now what I want to
add here is myself I think I want this
once page yes good I've subtracted this
we know looking turn okay which is kind
of like a cross between these two since
I've subtracted it in order to actually
not muck around with my fractions I'm
gonna add it as well so I'm gonna get
this I told you your columns are gonna
break right - this okay right there okay
all right so just just to make sure you
know what you're doing here and you
might like to UM just because you know
when we're doing this and we're working
it out as we go everything makes sense
right now but in like a week or a month
you gonna come back you're like why did
we what's going on here so maybe in
another color put in for yourself okay
extra term added and subtracted added
you may even like to put for yourself a
reminder that this is very very similar
to what we do in rationalizing
denominators you multiply and you divide
by the same thing so it's no real change
okay all right now what if I got here
you can see this particular terms I've
added subtracted I can factorize I can
pair up of these four terms I can pair
them up in different ways okay so I'm
gonna write that down
once my limits at the front and here the
first two the common term is what can I
factorize out good H okay and then what
I'm left with is okay there's the first
one over here the common factor is just
B okay so there's at the foot and what
about the brackets is happy so far all
right now why have I done this by the
way the reason why I added and
subtracted this is just so I could get
to this factorization what's useful
about this factorization much like
what's useful about you know the
conjugate that that factorization is hot
the TR in this case was difference of
squares what do I have here let me try
making a little bit obvious to you I've
got two terms show the numerator so
really I can break this apart into two
fractions that are completely separate
okay there's this one which is earned on
H right and I've got this one which is
over H daniken all right now just for a
second ignore this right-hand side
fraction just look at the left hand one
are there any features in there that
looked familiar
or useful yeah
ya know just like this is not just
application but it is something
important once or something
I'll see you put it what's in front of
each other
where other where other my track for it
oh how suspicious right look at this guy
right over H and we're taking the limit
does this not look identical to what we
had in the first line except with v's
instead of F's
okay and you also have this really
impressive you buy at the front okay so
in order to make this a little better
I've got really four things here okay
one one two three and four so what I'm
gonna do is gonna get worse right is I'm
going to take all four things and take
the limit separately of all of them okay
take a limit every single one so watch
this here we go at the front of my limit
is H approaches zero of the first term
which is just u on X plus h that okay
then I multiply by the limit of this
whole fraction that's left so I've got
the limit as H approaches zero of this
guy over H I've left these two as the
fraction together because like I said
it's just that first resort okay so
there's my first two limits and then I
have another two everything up as sorry
H approaches 0 of the and then limit as
H approaches zero again now can you see
why I told you to ignore this side
because basically it's just like the
first but with use instead of these
okay
so again just like we did here you might
like to put down some extra description
for yourself here why are we doing this
why are we breaking it apart in so many
pieces to make the first principle was
obvious okay it's there twice okay
all right sir I told you that I break
your columns right but fortunately for
me I have bigger cause can you so I'm
gonna keep on going over here we've got
four limits okay let's just consider
them one by one number one um X + H as H
approaches zero the whole point of doing
first bits wasn't that um thing is to
simplify as far as you can so you can
just put that limit in so you can
evaluate the limit and I've got no
problem see H is not on the denominator
so I can just slap a an H equals zero so
when H equals zero that limit is just U
of X is it that the H is gone and we
said this guy was like first principles
this is what you get when you're trying
to differentiate a function okay so this
is V - thanks dad okay all right then
you get the next part this is even
easier than the first one
what's V of X is H approach zero well
has nothing to do with H right so it
does it just you know keeps on rolling
on and doesn't care what value H takes
so to speak okay and then your next part
is you okay
so I can just write this without my on
all of my brackets because they're just
really
I'm giving me a bit extra information
telling me that all of these letters
right they're not just printed rules
they're actually standing for functions
of X but to make it neat up and just
gonna write it without them I'm gonna
write it like on this I'm gonna reverse
the order actually this apart or maybe
if I put it up the front what was I
actually differentiating right what did
I start with I was differentiating u
times B right so the derivative of U
times me if you would be a functions not
pretty much okay here's the way I
remembered it when you start with a move
and you end with a full okay it's not
actually happening but other than like
you could be like start with them start
with an AB and then end with a good
Apple or something anywhere now by the
way you might be wondering I had use
first here and while I put V these first
here the reason why is when we get to
the question rule even though here the
order doesn't matter it's a sum so you
can take P 1 whichever way you want with
the question which we're going to look
at later the water does matter and this
is the order it must be in okay so
you'll see that later but I figure
you've got nothing else to remember I
want to try and make them sort of closer
to each other so you don't have to
remember as much alright so that's the
product rule can we come back to our
example we said the derivative of x
squared times x squared minus 1
okay so how do you do this like I said I
know you can do this by expansion okay
but later one will meet the kinds of
functions that you can't just expand out
so let's practice what we're doing here
what I do when I see a product is I get
out another color or if you're lazy use
the same color and I label each function
okay now again cuz the prod the order
doesn't matter right this could be V and
this could be human
I just put him out finding water so the
derivative of F is a fool okay so here
we go I write this down again it's a
formula not because it gets marks but
because it just helps me remember what's
the my steps are gonna go through
so what's V it's x squared minus one
okay and then I'm up to you - which is
the derivative of this first part which
is Suez okay good then we take it into
reverse order so now I put in you which
is just x squared and my V dash which we
already established was Sudan's okay so
now when I expand this all that you get
your 2x cubed minus 2x plus 2x cubed
which is 4x cubed minus 3x which is what
we got in the first place okay so
product rule there works there are any
questions about any of these steps like
I said you don't have to reproduce this
thing but I still want you to understand
like where does this come from like if I
just given this to you at the beginning
you'd be like move move what why I don't
know it just works okay this is why it
works it's it's a legit result and it
just makes sense because of first
principles which you already understand